all these mobsters that are now getting
out of jail after 20 years 25 years
podcasting you know what they're doing
they're all doing podcasts
they're they're all doing they're all
they have like youtube channels and they
have huge followings
interesting you killed 19 people cool go
away he puts john gotti away yeah man
and then he comes back he's telling
stories people love him dude he's
telling he's one of the best
storytellers i've ever heard he was
telling the story about how they got
this guy john john um doesn't matter
yeah johnny lee johnny lee who was head
of their there was a war going on
one family i think the genovese and
gambinos they couldn't get to him
because he was surrounded by 30 dudes so
he says
so he goes in and he goes tell him i'm a
punk and i want to bring a message from
paul castellano so he goes into this
diner and the guys are knocking them out
of their 30 guys just by hey tough guy
and he said look if you go there and you
say that paul wants to meet him and they
don't believe you they're going to take
you down in that basement they're going
to torture you yeah and and you know so
it's all this stuff long story short he
gets the guy and this guy johnny johnny
lee who was
like the hit man's hitman and he was he
ran this whole crew and if they killed
him they knew the war would be over
they'd win the war so long story short
he samuel has to pretend he's he's a
total like he's he's just like i can't
get some water i'm so nervous i just i'm
just trying to give you the message you
know i just wanted to know his exactness
he wants to meet you somewhere you pick
the spot but he wants to do it alone
they go meet a country club uh the
country club i belong to great they got
a van waiting he goes i'm going to walk
when i go by the van i'm going to
stutter step i'm going to get like a
couple in spam i'm going to bear hug him
open that [ __ ] door i'm going to pull
him in and then hold him down one more
time drama long story short they get him
and the [ __ ] guy's sitting there and
he looks at him he's like this he goes
unbelievable punk huh you're the you're
the messenger boy huh you had me going
you had me going sammy and he goes hey
it is what it is and then he goes now he
had to wait to get a call okay to kill
him and it was going to be if he hit the
side of the van once
he's let him go
twice
i got to kill you oh so now so these
guys are all killers right and the dude
the dude is sitting there like this and
he's remember he has 50 bodies to hit
the sky that he's got and he goes like
this he goes hey jerk off
and sami goes what he goes
cover the back window he goes what do
you mean he goes
because there are a bunch of truckers
here if they look in the back window
they're going to see me tied up and
they're going to call the cops i'm not
going out that way you don't want to go
out their way cover the back oh wow so
sammy the bull goes what a gangster this
[ __ ] is telling me how to do a
hit he goes to chris
he goes santa ball goes this guy's a
stupid [ __ ] gangster he had a respect
for him yeah now now he goes he goes all
of a sudden i'm like what kind of a guy
do i have here yeah and then he goes
like this he goes they start talking and
he goes
he goes uh
he goes sammy do me a favor in my pocket
there's a i got pills you got to put one
under my tongue and the guy goes sami
goes why he goes i got pains in my chest
it's nitroglycerin i don't want to die
by heart attack i'm not going out like
that i look like a [ __ ]
so sammy goes he knows
gonna kill him it gets better puts it
under his [ __ ] tongue like that and
and he goes like that now if i don't get
better in five minutes put another one
under my tongue you got me you hear me
listen to me so sammy's like this
[ __ ]
he's crazy yeah then he goes like this
then he goes like this he looks at me he
goes
you're one of us he goes guys
and then he goes like this he goes
i can make you a rich man you let me go
you know that right and sammy goes i got
too much respect for you right now don't
do that and he goes i'm not i was just
testing you oh
i was just testing him he goes good no
money right not
not all the money worthless not all the
money in world goes good boy
then he goes like this then he goes like
this he gets a boom boom no no he here
they hear walking but nobody's banging
on the truck yeah he goes if it's a cop
shoot that [ __ ]
shoot him
i want to see him die before i go
wow so now he's like what kind of a
[ __ ] do i have here yeah what
kind of [ __ ] got us he gets the
bang the double yeah
he goes you lost the decision
at this point it's been 13 hours he got
him coffee 13 hours jesus christ so
they're hanging out yeah he goes i love
this man he goes this man embodied
everything about cousin astra that i
could ever think of he goes i fell in
love with this guy and and i didn't [ __ ]
him and he goes like this basically and
he goes like this he gets he goes like
this he goes you lost the decision bro i
gotta kill you
and he goes
can you do me a favor and he goes
anything and he goes take my shoes off
when i don't want them find me with my
shoes on he goes why i guess oh i always
told my my wife i'd die with my shoes
off meaning i'd die at home my shoes off
she thought i'd die like a dog in the
street and that's the way it is she
knows this life
and and sammy goes done done so he takes
his shoes off for him and then they try
to drag him out let's get your [ __ ]
hands off him get your [ __ ] hands off
him he goes he goes john you want you
want you want to roll out yourself and
he goes yeah let me roll out myself and
he goes he goes and he introduces him he
goes he's one of ours he's a made guy
his name was uh uh ray alito or whatever
yeah ray's going to be ray's going to
shoot you he's going to he's going to do
the killing so he goes he introduces him
like it's all formal jesus christ and he
goes
do me a favor just walk about four four
feet into the
weeds duck your head and he's gonna kill
you just like that and the guy goes all
right
good boy
keep your head out of trouble and just
[ __ ] shot him in the head just took
his took
four steps bend his head boom and then
he shot him three more times they found
him with his shoes off jesus christ bro
he tells these stories where you're just
of course [ __ ] life
he talks about getting made he talks
about the the
getting paid the whole ceremony he goes
he goes have put on a white shirt a tie
and your best suit and meet me on this
corner now here's the problem with that
sometimes
yeah sometimes you think you're getting
made and you're never coming back what
exactly it's the best day of your life
the worst day of your life exciting life
but never ends well for down they go
down to the [ __ ] they go down the
basement paul castellano is there the
head of the gambino crime family and all
the other made guys and they're all
sitting there and he goes you know these
people he goes yeah he goes
you swear this is a secret society where
cause the nostra what finger do you do
you pull the trigger with he points at
that they burn the finger they do some
ritual in italian he says all these
italian words then they all hold hands
and they they do some weird like i don't
know some talk and he goes now from now
on and then they go through a list of
what's what what is constitutes a death
penalty if you raise your hand to a
friend of ours meaning another main guy
you die if you introduce
yourself to somebody else as a maid guy
to somebody who's not you you that's the
definition this is great so you have to
be introduced by somebody else who's
made to somebody else who's made
it it's [ __ ] rules that's cool that
is [ __ ] great
well you can see how some guys get the
wife
well even the head of uh the guy he was
the youngest uh head of the hells angels
chapter he's 22. wow